[Música]
cuáles son hoy sus juegos preferidos
seguramente la respuesta mayoritaria
hacia forma para los que no lo conocen
el ford night es un juego online en el
cual estás en una isla y tener que
pelear contra otros jugadores como los
juegos del hambre este juego es el que
hoy en día está de moda
algún otro juego incluso que no sea
digital
esto es muy difícil no sea de la mayoría
juanjo digitales ustedes saben que
existen otros juegos que podríamos
llamar pre digitales bueno esto es una
metáfora para referirme a todos los
juguetes que no son ni virtuales ni
última tecnología y usar electricidad
por ejemplo el año pasado estuvimos
todos jugando un largo rato con fidget
spinner que era un juguete vieja escuela
tipo clásico pero cuáles son los
verdaderos juguetes clásicos
pensemos por ejemplo en el balero el
yoyo el trompo hay muchos más pero hay
uno sobre el cual me quiero referir
especialmente
el año pasado que eeuu con mi papá
estuvimos visitando una librería
gigantes que tiene una sección de
juguetería que no te la puedes ni
imaginar yo hace tiempo que quería
conseguir este juego lo deseaba
en esta juguetería yo no es mala buena
cabrón
ruiz
es la de cabro el primer contacto que
tuvo con un cubo rubik fue los cinco
años pero prestó una amiga de mi mamá
este cubo tenía en cada cuadradito una
escuadra no le había prestado mucha
atención ya que hizo unos movimientos y
lo decía pero antes de irme a dormir lo
dejar armado al lado de mi cama cuando
me desperté lo encontré desarmado y de
allí nació mi interés
el cubo tradicional es el tres por tres
tiene nueve cuadraditos por cara
en este cubo se pueden lograr miles de
millones de combinaciones
pero hay dos objetivos en general armar
los bien y resolver los rápidos el
desafío de la velocidad doble buscar el
camino más rápido para armarlo
en este caso mi récord es de 34 segundos
que acaso no me creen están desafiando
aunque
con un cronómetro
[Aplausos]
no lo creo ni yo
igual sin embargo el récord en humanos
aproximadamente 5 segundos esto es una
locura 2 que en el 3 por 3 se puede
llegar a lograr miles de millones de
combinaciones sin embargo se puede
resolver unos en unos 21 movimientos
cuando entré con un cubo rubik a mi
clase mis compañeros dijeron que era
raro y hablando con ellos me di cuenta
que mis gustos son internos y diferentes
a los suyos por ejemplo yo no escucho
trap sino de mostra michael jackson o
queens
una amiga me dijo que tendría que vernos
en los años 80 pero se quedaron sin
espacio y me metieron acá
igualmente el cubo rubik tiene sus
ventajas
puedes estimula memoria estimula también
el pensamiento matemático te ayuda a ver
los movimientos
las consecuencias de lo que hagas
y también la manera de ver las cosas
nuestros profesores perdón tendrían que
estar encantados de que los usemos
seguramente para muchos de ustedes el
cubo rubik haya nacido como un juguete
pero no el cual nace como un proyecto
diseño de ernö rubik artista y diseñador
húngaro
con él
un objetivo para ayudar a las personas a
estimular lo que les dije antes que es
pensamiento matemático
las consecuencias de lo que hagas etc
durante los años 80 se desató una
verdadera manía y se vendieron millones
de modelos por todo el mundo
esta manía le dio lugar a muchos modelos
nuevos hay cubos que aumenta aumentar
las filas o sea los cuadrados por cara
pueden ser cuatro por cuatro o cinco por
cinco
y después hay cubos que no son tales por
llegar a ser pirámides dodecaedro
etcétera
las personas son fanáticas usualmente
tienen muchos modelos a la vez yo en
este momento tengo 15
como pueden ver no olvide también de
unos modelos que pueden llegar a tener
engranajes otros que son todo el mismo
color y usted se puede llegar a
preguntar cuál es el desafío ahí la cosa
es que las piezas son de diferentes
tamaños lo cual el desafío va a ser el
werder mano en un cubo
el objetivo de esta charla para
contarles mi pasión por los cubos rob es
acompañarlos a conocer el mundo que los
rodea y sus curiosidades entonces yo les
digo aflojen un poco con lo virtual le
dejo una invitación a jugar distinto
[Aplausos]